mais l'appel à la population pour
attirer la faveur populaire c'est-à-dire
j'ouvre les conventions collectives le
conjugue au 21ème siècle ça veut dire
quoi pour vous des de revoir les façons
de choses de vous revoir comment on
s'organise on est ouvert a soutenu toute
mesure qui va rendre la médecine
familiale plus attractive qui vont lui
donner des moyens de mieux s'organiser
qui va favoriser l'accès on va toujours
être très rare garde des sceaux pour
garder cependant qu'actuellement on a
une convention on a déjà des mesures qui
vont en france là je comprends monsieur
legault c'est qu'il semble dire je suis
prêt à en faire plus si je les prenne en
faire plus on pourra regarder mais
justement qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
regarder parce qu'encore des files
d'attentes initiales sont pas encore et
toujours dans une situation où on manque
de médecins de famille vous savez là il
ya dix ans on avait autant de médecins
de famille que de médecins spécialistes
aujourd'hui le ya 500 médecins
spécialistes de plus que des médecins de
famille les médecins de famille la
croissance de mon nombre de médecins
suis à peine la croissance de la
populaire de nous voulons la pension oui
j'en ai de nouveau mais j'ai 500
nouveaux médecins mais dans les faits
j'aurais 130 nouveaux médecins de
famille en bout de ligne donc ce qu'il
faut que je fasse à court terme il faut
je les aide à mieux s'organiser ici on
nous donne plus de ressources on va être
capable de mieux s'organiser on va
probablement être capable d'en faire
plus et si j'investis en médecine
familiale que je rends sur plus
attrayant dans les cris ni mes yeux plus
de médecins qui vont choisir les une
querelle entre vous et votre collègue et
médecins spécialistes qui prétend que
vous pouvez vraiment faire plus très que
vous ne faites pas déjà n'en fait pas
assez encore écouter les besoins par
rapport à ce que dit le dernier empereur
laquelle par excellence que ce que dit
ce que dit le dr barrette là qu'ils
regardent d'abord ce que ces médecins
spécialistes font regarde donc la
croissance des médecins spécialistes a
été beaucoup plus grande que celle des
médecins de famille et qu'on règle des
situations comme on actuellement
sherbrooke on n'est pas capable d'avoir
un dermatologue partians nos pots qu'on
règle les délais d'attentes pour que les
gens soient capables de ravoir un examen
et qu'il s'occupe de son et nous on va
s'occuper de la médecine de famille